juneteenth is going to be a federal
holiday for reasons teachers won't be
allowed to explain to their students out
of fear or critical race theory backlash
um actually celebrating juneteenth is
precisely counter to critical race
theory
and the people pushing it have nothing
but malignant intentions for what comes
next year
meanwhile controversy breaking out oddly
enough
mainly from the left over juneteenth so
yesterday
congress adopted pretty much unanimously
there are a few people who voted against
it
to make juneteenth a national federal
holiday now juneteenth
is the date in which slaves in texas
were finally informed about the
emancipation proclamation
and it happened like two years after the
emancipation proclamation and so it's
been celebrated in black communities
around the united states as sort of the
marking the end the date marking the end
of slavery
for decades truly decades and so now
it's been made a federal holiday and as
i said yesterday on the program not only
do i not have a problem with this
i think that it's quite good that we
have a federal holiday marking the end
of slavery
because that was a signal moment in
america's history
it seems to me that we should absolutely
celebrate the end of slave
that whether that should be on june 10th
or whether that should be upon the
ratification of the 13th and 14th
amendments to the united states
constitution
the the revivification of the promises
of the declaration of independence
under the auspices of the lincoln
administration and the end of slavery
and the establishment of equality before
law at least
in at least in the constitution and then
gradually effectuated over time
so that now there is full equality
before law in the united states and if
you don't believe that you should read
some of the laws of the united states
sometime
that is well worth celebrating that is a
very good thing now what the left was
saying is that they want juneteenth
to be made a federal law so that we can
basically club americans
by saying that if they don't now agree
with our racial agenda then
it's because they don't understand the
legacy of juneteenth the legacy of
juneteenth is racial progress right it
is literally marking racial progress in
the united states
and there's been a lot more racial
progress as it turns out between 1865
and 2021
okay so it seems that that should be a
date that frankly everybody should
celebrate right i mean that's a very
very good thing that slavery ends in the
united states this is undisputed
but the left is is using this as an
excuse as they always do everything is
an excuse to push for more
always so you have a person named steed
herndon
okay at a steed wesley on twitter he's a
national political reporter based in new
york for the new york times
is a reporter not an opinion guy and he
is very upset
that juneteenth became a national
holiday yesterday and voted nearly
unanimously
unanimously in the senate with like
total support from everyone
he says that what's what's truly amazing
is that many of the same people who are
voting to make juneteenth the national
holiday
also oppose critical race theory a
critical race theory is not
juneteenth critical race theory is the
belief that all of america's
institutions
are irrevocably intertwined with racism
that they are shot through with racism
that they are so poisoned at the root
that all of the branches are just fruit
of the poisonous tree
that is the basic idea of critical race
theory that whiteness
is is present in everything that racism
is a normal state of the world
that people don't even acknowledge their
own racism and that people benefit
from that racism okay and that kids are
supposed to be taught this
now here's the reality so what did this
guy tweet out what did this reporter
this national political reporter st
herndon tweeted out for the new york
times quote it's kind of amazing
juneteenth is going to be a federal
holiday for reasons teachers won't be
allowed to explain to their students out
of fear or critical race theory backlash
um what i'm pretty sure americans know
about slavery
turns out that we were all literally all
of us taught about slavery in school
from the time we were children
we are all very much aware of slavery
and that's why juneteenth is a national
holiday
to end slavery but notice how the left
conflates all the issues right all the
issues are the same always and forever
all of them and if you if you
apparently quote unquote give the left
an incident i don't think this is giving
left an inch i don't think it's giving
them anything frankly to celebrate the
end of slavery again i think that's a
pretty unifying thing
but if you give them what they perceive
to be an inch they then proceed to try
and take it for a mile
and that mile is indoctrinating your
children and the idea that america's
institutions are irrevocably racist
which by the way is the precise reverse
of what juneteenth is
juneteenth is a recognition that
america's institutions changed and
morphed
and molded and adapted in order to be
less racist
right the reality is the constitutional
provisions fourth amendment were
utilized in order to end slavery in the
united states
the reality is that it was america's
legal process
that was changed by the law under the
systems and institutions of the united
states in order to effectuate
the end of legalized racism in the
united states
so actually celebrating juneteenth is
precisely counter to critical race
theory
which suggests i mean derek bell openly
suggested this
that racism in the united states has
gotten worse not better juneteenth is a
precise rebuke and rebuttal of that idea
but the media have decided
that basically you have to accept if you
are racially sensitive you have to
accept that america's a more racist
place a more terrible place and you have
to allow the indoctrination of your
children
in this particular idea that is of
course absolute stupidity
there's a reason why there is a backlash
and that backlash is going to be
extremely strong
i am perfectly willing and so is every
other american i know to hear about the
flaws of the united states what i'm not
willing to hear is that the united
states is at root a racist horrifying
country and our institutions are bad
that is not true
it's a patent and absurd lie on its face
and
people pushing it have nothing but
malignant intentions for what comes next
here
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight and top of
your feed